what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home if you
thought that the hype would calm down
after the first trailer came out well
that does not seem to be the case this
trailer pretty much only made the hype
get even bigger showing us a glimpse of
the spider-verse that is to come by
showing us alfred molina's doc ock
showing us a pumpkin bomb and other
parts of the sinister six as well now we
did not see the other two spider-man
andrew garfield and toby maguire but
have no fear they will be in the movie
whether or not they'll show them in the
next trailer or the one after that or
simply save them for the movie who knows
but in the meantime i think i have
something that could hold people over
for just a little bit we have some of
their lines that they're going to be
saying in spider-man no way home
speaking to each other speaking to tom
holland spider-man speaking to the
villains all from a very reliable source
in fact this source gave us a
description of what the teaser trailer
was going to show weeks before it even
came out and when it came out it was
pretty much exactly like this person
said and i know you are really going to
enjoy some of these lines like this line
that comes from toby speaking to tom and
andrew he says we can beat them together
obviously this is about them fighting
the sinister six so lots of cool stuff
to break down today but first i'm going
to show you something so incredibly cool
that i think a lot of you are going to
really really like
thank you so much to display for
sponsoring this video and sending me
these awesome posters displayed is a
one-of-a-kind metal poster with a
revolutionary magnetic mounting system
there are zero tools required to mount
this on your wall it's very safe for
your wall and since they're magnetic you
can swap them in and out these posters
are of insanely high quality and they
are super durable since they're printed
on metal each one is printed on demand
and these are licensed products for
example this loki poster is a licensed
marvel poster there are over 1.4 million
designs that you can choose from ranging
anywhere from movies to comics marvel dc
star wars sports or if you're a k-pop
fan like me k-pop also one disc plate
sold equals one tree planted so you're
doing some good here too and they have
really fast delivery on these two when
you order them if you love posters this
plate is the way to go and you can get a
discount when you click on the link in
the description down below
so the line i want to start with even
though i've already given you one is one
that i find particularly pretty funny
and i've seen several memes about this
line already and it is is this stuff
coming out of you this is from tom
holland to toby who of course toby is
the only spider-man that we've seen who
actually produces the webs he doesn't
actually have web shooters and this is
something that i've actually always
personally liked about toby maguire
spider-man now i'm not going in any
particular order of the movie just
simply stating some of the lines that
are listed here and another one is from
william defoe to tom holland spider-man
where he says the wizard said he'd get
us back to where we came from but we
can't go back now obviously this is the
green goblin talking to tom holland
spider-man and he's saying they can't go
back because they were taken right from
where they died so if they get sent back
to their own universe they'll get sent
back to right before they died and it'll
lead to them dying so obviously they
don't want to go back and speaking of
them dying here's a line from electro to
andrew garfield spider-man well well if
it isn't my murderer because we all know
what happened at the end of the amazing
spider-man 2. here's an interesting one
this is willem dafoe's green goblin to
tom holland spider-man and he says we
are who we choose to be now choose and
this kind of sounds like the green
goblin is manipulating tom probably
telling him something along the lines of
the other spider-man killed us do you
want to be a killer you don't have to be
the other spider-man were but you don't
have to be you can set us free pretty
much right now we know that doctor
strange is going to somehow keep all of
these villains locked up and
unfortunately it's tom holland
spider-man that lets them out and it
sounds like it somehow might be due to
the manipulation of the green goblin he
also posted this weeks before the
trailer came out and here's a line that
we saw in the trailer you've never done
anything on this magnitude strange don't
cast that spell it's too dangerous wong
to doctor strange we saw this and just
for reference this was literally posted
like 50 days ago so way before the
trailer came out so all of this is
legitimate here's another electro to
andrew garfield line i'm gonna kill the
light so everyone in this city is gonna
know how it feels to live in my world a
world without power a world without
mercy a world without spider-man he
seems like he could be just a tiny bit
bitter and the cool thing is is that it
does also kind of seem like some of the
lines are going to come from their
original movies or at least derived from
them for example here's a line from
willem the foe's green goblin to tom
holland spider-man the itsy bitsy spider
climbed up the water spout down came the
goblin and took the spider out sounds a
little familiar huh and i can't wait
till he actually says this to our
spider-man tom holland spider-man here's
another one that was in the trailer
again proving this is true because this
was 50 days ago doctor strange to tom
holland we tampered with the stability
of space-time another one that was
proven true after mysterio revealed my
identity my entire life got screwed up i
was wondering if maybe you can go back
in time and make it so that he never did
and here are four lines that i really
really love and i think a lot of people
if you are big big spider-man fans which
i know a lot of us are are probably
going to get pretty teary-eyed at some
point in time in this movie whether it's
an emotional scene or it's just simply
seeing all three spider-man together
whether they're happy tears emotional
tears i think they're coming this is one
from the very first spider-man that hits
me right in the nostalgia toby to willem
dafoe i have a father his name was ben
parker in which it seems like willem
dafoe says god speed spider-man but he
says this not to toby maguire but he
says it to tom holland then this is from
toby to tom your ben how did he die and
you automatically know this is going to
be a super emotional scene and the last
line that is listed here says you're not
alone you have us toby and andrew to tom
now if you can just visualize these
scenes visualize toby mcguire and andrew
garfield and tom holland all talking to
each other you can get a tiny little
glimpse of just how epic this film is
going to be and just based off of some
of this dialogue i can tell like most of
the leaks have said willem the foe's
green goblin is most likely going to be
the main villain and leader here of the
sinister six however and i'll be sure to
mention this in another video that i'll
be doing soon it does seem like sandman
might actually be a good guy after all
at the end of spider-man 3 him and toby
maguire spider-man parted ways kind of
peacefully peter said i forgive you and
the sandman went away he didn't actually
die i think he's the only villain that
didn't actually die so all this revenge
and this bitterness that all of these
villains have sandman doesn't really
have that if he gets sent home he'll
probably just get sent back to his sick
daughter which is probably something
that he wants so there is the
possibility that he could actually be a
good guy but i'll talk about that in
another video now of course i want to
end it with the biggest and best line
that we could possibly ever get in this
spider-man no way home film it would be
a waste if we did not hear these words
toby maguire to tom holland don't ever
forget these words with great power
comes great responsibility seriously if
you don't feel something during this
line in the movie when it happens i
don't even know what to tell you just
reading it knowing that it comes from
toby maguire to tom holland gives me
chills and i really really really hope
that we see it in the movie again this
was all posted about 50 days ago way
before the trailer came out and this
person also posted a description of the
trailer which ended up being true and
some of these lines in here we heard in
the trailer so we have no reason not to
believe that these aren't actual lines
actual dialogue that is going to be in
spider-man no way home so just another
confirmation of andrew garfield and toby
maguire and some awesome lines from
what's going to be a pretty epic movie
so let me know what you think about
these in the comments down below and if
you want to stay up to date on
everything in the mcu and spider-man be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and of
course for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof